"Jurassic World: Dominion"
hits theaters June 10th.
Chris and I are about to do
the "Face It Challenge."
Here we go.
-♪ Face it ♪
-♪ Face It Challenge ♪
-Now here's how it works.
Each round, I'll draw a card,
which will tell us what face
we both have to make, okay?
Then we'll look in our mirrors,
make our faces,
and then reveal them
on the count of three,
and we'll stare at each other
for 10 seconds.
-Oh! Got it.
-Uh-huh.
-So we both
are making the same face.
-Correct.
-Now I get it.
-Now, the first person
to crack a smile, laugh,
or break the face loses.
-Oh, no.
Okay.
-Okay?
Let's see
what our first face is.
Here we go.
All right, this one's
"holding in a yawn."
-Okay, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
Hold on.
[ Laughs ]
Wait, hold on.
[ Laughter ]
Wait, all right.
3, 2, 1, go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
Holding in a yawn?
-Unh-unh.
-[ Laughs ]
I was like...
That was a good yawn!
-I didn't even do
"holding in a yawn."
I just tried
to make you me laugh.
-You made me laugh.
All right,
that's an interesting strategy.
I like that.
I was actually
trying to swallow one.
All right.
Let's do another one here.
This is...
"pretending you love a present."
-Oh, got it, got it.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
Three, two, one.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I did the same face.
[ Both laugh ]
That was a good bit.
You did the same face!
That's so funny!
Gosh, that's such
a good strategy.
-I won't do it --
-No, but that was so funny.
You're "pretending
to hold a yawn" face.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the only face you make.
It's very funny.
-I won't do it again.
That's good.
Here we go.
Let's do another one.
[ Laughter ]
"Cinco de Mayo at 3:00 a.m."
-Oh, yeah!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-All right, three, two, one.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
Stop doing that.
Stop doing that!
[ Both laugh ]
-All right, all right.
I'm gonna actually do
a real one this time.
[ Laughter ]
-It's so stupid,
it makes me laugh.
Oh, I love it.
All right, here's one.
There's one more round.
Here's the last one here.
This one is --
Oh, you'll be good at this.
-Yeah, I got this one.
-"Velociraptor is standing
right behind you."
-Like, you're trying
to convey to a person
that they're standing
right behind you, or --
Yeah, yes, 'cause otherwise,
you wouldn't know
if it was standing behind you.
-No, I think you would know.
-I'm telling you
that a velociraptor
is standing behind you,
or am I just --
-Would you know?
-'Cause if they're standing
behind you, I'd just be making
this face.
I wouldn't know.
-I know, but what --
-They're sneaky.
-Oh, they are sneaky.
-I wouldn't know.
-You wouldn't really know?
-I'd know.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
I'm a scientist.
I know these things.
A velociraptor is standing
behind me, and I know.
-Okay.
So, the idea is that
I'm gonna have to do it --
My thing is, I'm gonna
be telling you that there is
a velociraptor behind you,
like, over there.
-Or is it that
that's happening, and you're
like, "What just happened?"
[ Laughter ]
Like, I don't think it's just --
"I don't know
what's standing behind me."
Is there something behind me?
-Can we keep it moving?
[ Laughter ]
Is there something
behind me right now?
-Yeah, that's gonna be the face.
I'm doing there's a velociraptor
standing behind you.
-Oh, I'm doing there's a
velociraptor standing behind me.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah, all right.
-Yeah, yeah.
-We got this.
-Oh, no, you're right.
It's standing right behind you.
-Like, there's a velo--
Is it in quotes?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
"You" is in quotes.
-Yeah.
-It's standing behind "you."
Yeah, "you" is in quotes.
-Is there an emphasis?
[ Laughter ]
-There's an emphasis
on "behind."
Okay. Ready?
-Let's poll the audience.
Do you have "Millionaire"
technology?
Can we poll the audience?
-Here we go.
-Oh, God.
-"Velociraptor standing
right behind you."
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
Same thing as me.
Okay. Behind you.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Three, two, one.
[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
I knew you were gonna do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Chris Pratt, everybody!
That's how you do it.
That's how you make me laugh.
Oh, you're a funny dude.
Love you, bud.